such an arbitrary combination of factors
that are external for one another yields
no law physiognomies supposed to differ
from other questionable arts and
pernicious studies because it considers
specific individuality in the necessary
antithesis of an inner and an outer of
character as a conscious disposition and
this again as an existent shape and the
way it relates these factors to each
other is the way they are related by
their notion hence these factors must
constitute the content of a law in
astrology palmistry and similar sciences
on the other hand what seems to be
related is only an outer to an outer
something or other to an element alien
to it this particular constellation at
birth and when this external element is
brought closer to the body these
particular lines on the hand are
external factors indicating a longer or
shorter life and the fate in general of
the particular individual being
externalities they are indifferent
towards each other and lack the
necessity for one another that want to
lie in the relation of an outer to an
inner
paragraph 314 sees us picking up where
the previous paragraph 313 left off and
talking about something that is
completely arbitrary and contingent so
remember back what hegel had talked
about is the body being essentially
reduced to a thing which meant that it
became a sign which meant that it was
incorporated into some sort of
contingent or as he said capricious
system of signs and so he talks about
this by saying such an arbitrary
combination of factors that are external
for one another yields no law and we're
very interested once again in seeing
whether we can find a lot so the rest of
this paragraph what hegel is doing is
compared is comparing and contrasting
physiognomies physiognomic which was a
new acknowledged as pseudoscience Hagel
recognized that as a pseudoscience in
his own time but it was quite popular at
the time against other things that were
now being more readily recognized as
essentially pseudo-sciences that is
things pretending to the level or the
sophistication or the predictability of
science but not really providing that
and the two examples that he gives here
are astrology and palmistry astrology I
think we're all familiar with palmistry
is when people read your palm they look
at your hand and they say oh your
lifeline very long you're going to live
a long time but look your love line
there's going to be breaks here and
there so Hagel is not actually endorsing
this but he's saying this is the way
that people think about physiognomies so
what does physiognomies do it at least
purports to relate an inner an inner of
the human being to the outer and what is
the outer thee as he calls an existence
shape the Zion der Gestalt and what is
the inner the the conscious disposition
the boost evason the the being the
essence that is conscious that is
consciousness and in both cases we have
character right character is an inner
character is also displayed in an outer
and we just come through some paragraphs
where we talked about you know speech
and an action and how those those you
know display who we are but they also to
a certain degree escape us and this is
what physiognomic is supposed to be
dealing with its supposed to connect
these two together now he says by
contrast if we look at say astrology
palmistry and similar sciences what
seems to be related what what the person
who is asserting that as a type of
knowledge or the person who is being
taken in by it the person who reads
their horoscope in the paper and says oh
my goodness this describes me to a tee
I'd better follow this the person is
being taken in in part because there is
no relation of an inner to an outer
rather the relationship is merely that
of an outer to another outer an
externality to another externality so he
goes on and he says what we have here is
something or other to an element alien
to it there's no real relation between
these things there's no real relation
between your hand and he's going to
consider this in the following
paragraphs between your hand as the
palmist understands it and your life or
your fate or your destiny or anything
along those lines let alone your
character so he says you know this
particular constellation at birth and
when this external element is brought
closer to the body these particular
lines on the hand are external factors
indicating a longer and shorter life and
the Fate in general the particular
alright but there is no real connection
between them Hagel says and it's
interesting here to note that one thing
that occurs when we were talking about
pseudo-sciences is that merely being
able to criticize something else as a
pseudoscience doesn't establish what
you're doing is actually scientific this
is actually something really well worth
keeping in mind for the people who label
themselves as critical thinkers as
skeptics in the good sense you know
because sometimes what they're doing is
actually just as ad hoc and just as
thrown together just as unscientific as
what the people here are doing so the
fizzy the fizzy economists are saying
that look these things over here yes
they're unscientific but what we're
doing is scientific what's the basis
what's the pretension they're not just
relating one external thing that's
arbitrarily connected with another thing
instead they're relating an inner to an
outer like he says the way in which it
relates these factors to each other is
the way they are related by their notion
by their a gift by their concept so
there's supposed to be a kind of dynamic
relationship between the character
inside of a person which is going to be
displayed through their actions and
their words right and the character as
displayed by the physiography by the
face for example by those we're going to
see a little bit later the skull the
head by the way in which the body
displays itself standing up straight as
opposed to slouching over now smiling a
lot as opposed to a grouping mouth or
something like that right I mean we may
as well just to bring up a few silly
examples imagine if we were to apply
this rigorously in our own time and
think about all those crazy selfies with
duck faces and what a physique
my draw from that as regards the
character of the person you know very
fertile ground for for you know looking
at all these things or think about how
much variance we have just in a set of
photographs of the same person in
different circumstances but here's the
the upshot because for the physique no
missed the there is a relation between
the inner and outer by the notion that
means that what we have here is a law
that means that that we can say that we
finally found the intelligibility that
we were looking for so as opposed to the
other pseudo-sciences this one is not a
pseudoscience and it is going to yield
us the intelligibility that allows us to
connect these things together
admittedly the hand does not seem to be
such a very external factor for fate it
seems rather to be related to it as
something enter for fate itself is also
only the manifestation of what the
particular individuality is in itself as
an inner original specific character now
to find out what this particular
individuality is in itself that the
palmist like the physiognomist takes a
shorter cut then for example Solan who
thought that he could only know this
from and after the course of the whole
life he examined the manifestation but
the former examines the unexploited in
itself that the hand however must
represent the in itself of the
individuality and respect of its fate is
easy to see from the fact that next to
the Oregon of speech it is the hand most
of all by which a man manifests and
actualizes himself it is the living
artifice er of his fortune we may say of
the hand that it is what a man does for
in it as the active organ of his self
fulfillment he is present as the
animating soul and since he is primarily
his own fate his hand will thus express
this in itself
in paragraph 3 15 it may appear to us at
first that Hagel is is is going back on
what he just said in the previous
paragraph with respect to palmistry
talking about the hand and its
significance because in the previous
paragraph you said that well palmistry
looks at the the hand but just as
something purely external but really the
hand is something inner when it comes to
an individual's fate their destiny what
it is that they are to be which includes
not only you know whether they're rich
or poor but what kind of relationships
they have what what sort of actions will
be determinative of them will they be a
thief will they be a king will they be a
great lover will they be unhappy or
destitute you know all these sorts of
things are a person's fate and if we
think about this is a bit of an aside
it's not as if we have our own fate
totally in isolation from everybody
else's fate that we could possibly think
of in the world but that's something
that we can hold on to it and come back
to later so let's look at what he what
he says here so he begins by saying the
hand does not seem to be such a very
external factor for fate and why is that
well the hand is what actually does
things so insofar as our fate is a
product of our action of what it is that
we do then the hand is really you might
say an inner factor in so far as we're
using this metaphorical language of
inner and outer that which is you know
understood as being driving or
determinative as opposed to that which
is determined so he says fate itself is
also only the manifestation of what the
particular individuality is in itself as
an original specific character he's got
here Miller and the translation but I
put determinacy here because that works
Forbush Tim
you know being determined being stimmt
being this way rather than that way
original is or sprung Lee you know
primordial is another way to translate
that so what it is that is in a person
is supposed to be there their fate
that's why you're not being supposed to
be able to escape your fate right
because you're born with it and it's
just the way it happens to me it'll
express itself so he says that to find
out what this particular individuality
is in itself in in what it is in its
being as such the palmist like the
physio economists so they're both really
on the same level here takes a shorter
cut than for example so one now who is
Solon Solon is an ancient Greek what's
calma statesman but also a poet who left
behind some very interesting writings
much of which have to do with the nature
of justice and Solon as we learn from
Herodotus said that we should count no
person happy until they're they're dead
that seems like an awfully long time to
wait but there's a whole story behind it
that we won't have to rehearse here you
can look it up it's in the first book of
Herodotus very early on and what's the
general idea behind this that soul that
is getting it well you know a person's
fate can go up or down this is what we
mean by you know the wheel of fortune
right it's not just a TV show it's also
a concept as we run throughout a
literature in the Western world the idea
is that the wheel goes down that's being
you know that you don't want to be on
the down side and the wheel swings back
up and so you're as we say / verbally
high on the hog for a while but if you
you know it's not going to stay that way
and so we can talk about the goods of
fortune and this leads into a lot of
interesting side paths that we don't
want to follow out at this point the
point is here that that's Solon thinks
that you need to look at a person if not
till the end of their
at least consistently over time and what
are you looking at so Solon says you
could only know that their fate from and
after the course of the whole life he
examined the manifestation he examined
what actually happens the relationship
between the actions of the person and
their ultimate culmination or you might
say the Nexus of the entire pattern on
the person's actions so he says the
former the palmist examines the in
itself not the for itself the for itself
isn't mentioned here but the for itself
is haunting this passage because what
determines the hand in so far as the
hand is something inner and its leading
to actions what we saw this in the
previous paragraphs didn't we the hand
is an expression or a manifestation of
the individuality as consciousness as
choice as self-determination as
something which is taking a stance upon
itself within the scope of the world and
the options that are available to it so
he goes on he says that the hand must
represent the in itself of the
individuality and respect to fade is
easy to see from this particular fact
and here Hagel is getting at something
quite profound that I don't actually
have on the chalkboard because it
doesn't fit into this schema but it's
something that we should think about and
explore next to the organ of speech the
mouth it is the hand most of all by
which a man manifests and actualizes
himself let's think about that for a
moment what are the things that we look
to in order to see who a person is in
order to make determinations about who
they are and what kind of person they
are and all the other things that go
along with that
you might say well we look at the face
and we're going to talk about the face a
little bit later on face is important
right now unless we're actually you know
kind of eccentric we don't worry about
things like their kneecaps or their
elbows or things like that we don't take
those is very expressive the hand we we
do but not in the way that the palmas
does we don't get somebody and look at
their hand and say what do you think of
that well it's not even a matter of
seeing well do you have dirt under your
fingernails or you have calluses or
things like that those those are
interesting but those are not as
significant if the hand does things the
hand is the doer and also that by which
it is done as we're going to talk about
a little bit later on Aristotle calls
the hand the tool of tools it is the
tool that drives the other tools and
what do we use tools for to get things
done to accomplish what it is that we
set for ourselves as means and for as
ends so the hand manifests what it is
that a person really wants what it is
that a person values what it is that a
person does as a matter of fact in a
certain way you could say that the hand
might actually be more honest in its
expression then the mouth is right
because we can contrast deeds and words
to use the ancient Greek way of talking
about a right and a lot of people would
say well I'm going to look at the deeds
not at the words here Hagel says that
the hand is not quite as expressive as
the organ of speech but it's pretty
close why it's the hand most of all by
which a man manifests and naturalizes
himself speech doesn't do that quite as
much so here's a beautiful phrase here
it's the living artificer of his fortune
so what it is that our fate or our
fortune or a destiny
is is really a matter of if we want to
be a little facetious what we do with
their hands look I'm talking with my
hands right now I'm actually talking
with my mouth but waving my hands around
it's it's what we do you know if he goal
was to consider for example these videos
I'm talking right now but these videos
are much more a product of the hand than
they are of the mouth why I turned on
the camera I set up this room I wrote
things on the truck where we're going to
get to writing and a few paragraphs from
now I'm doing all these sorts of things
my legs of course are involved because
they're moving me from place to place
right my face you're seeing that my
mouth is talking these these words
presumably my brain is involved as well
but all of these fall within the realm
metaphorically of the hand of action so
that's very important to keep in mind
the hand is he says the living artificer
the maker of a person's fortune so he
says we may see in the hand that it is
what a man does so it's not that we look
at the hand and see the lines on it and
say oh well those signify life or love
or wealth or anything like that rather
we look at the hand and we say wow this
hand has you know gotten you work in it
and a work that has come out of it and
that is what the hand really is so from
Hagel's perspective again to continue
this these videos in my channel are the
work of my hand they are what my hand is
they will continue to be so long after
I'm dead if these videos continue to be
watched something very interesting to to
think about if he goes on and he says as
the active organ of his self fulfillment
he is present as the animating soul
we're present in our hands again this is
why Aristotle can call the hand the tool
of tools if this
is a tool this is the tool that makes
this tool work if this is a tool again
this is the tool that makes it work same
thing with the recorder that I have same
thing with the camera same thing with
the lights that I've turned on all of
those are the fruit of my hand or some
sort of other intermediary that works
like a hand so he says since the person
is primarily their own fate the hand
will thus express this in itself so if
we want to look for a person's fate
again we don't do it by looking at the
fortuitous characteristics of the hand
even though it might be cool to like get
out a book and have somebody trace these
sorts of things that tells us nothing
what tells us something about a person
is what they actually do what their
actions signify
from this nature of the organ of
activity to be a passive being as well
as the action within it or from the fact
that the in itself nas's itself present
in it and has a being for others we
obtain another view of it than the
preceding namely if the organs in
general show themselves to be incapable
of being taken as expressions of the
inner because in them the action qui
action is present but the action qua
completed deed is merely external and
inner and outer in this way fall apart
and are or can be alien to each other
then the organ must now in accordance
with its nature be taken again is also a
middle term of both this very fact that
the action is present in it constitutes
an externality of it and moreover one
that is other than the deed for the
organ remains with and in the individual
now this middle term and unity of inner
and outer is in the first place itself
external to but then the Siq externality
is at the same time taken up into the
inner as simple externality it stands
over against the dispersed externality
which either is merely a single deed or
condition contingent for the
individuality as a whole or else as a
total externality is faith split up into
a multiplicity of Deeds and conditions
thus the simple lines of the hand the
timber and compass of the voice as the
individual characteristic of speech this
to again as expressed in writing where
the hand gives it a more durable
existence than the voice does especially
in the particular style of handwriting
all this isn't is an expression of the
inner so that as a simple externality
the expression again stands over against
the manifold externality of action and
fate stands in relation to them as an
inner thus if at first the specific
nature and innate peculiarity of the
individual together with what these have
become as a result of cultivation and
education are taken as the inner as the
essence of his action and his fate then
this essence has its appearance and
externality to begin with in his mouth
hand voice handwriting and the other
organs and their permanent
characteristics thereafter and not till
then does it give itself further
outward expression in its actual
existence in the world
paragraph 316 is a long-ish and very
important and interesting paragraph
because Hagel as we've seen him do so
many times before in the past likes to
bring in this notion of the middle term
something that mediates something that
connects things together almost like a
syllogism the term that he uses over and
over again in the this phenomenology
also in his logic again if you want to
see how he treats the syllogism the
logic the science of logic is the place
to go here we need to think of this in
terms of mediation in terms of bringing
the things together and somehow
integrating them filling in the gaps you
might say and what are the gaps well
between the inner of the individual the
individuality and the outer what is what
is being expressed by them and you know
we can talk about this outer in terms of
the determinate shape the gestalt of the
the person may be looking at their hand
may be looking at their face may be
looking at their form altogether but
even more so what has been externalized
through their action through their
speech and through other things that
we're going to find to be significant it
as well in this paragraph for example
we're going to have a hybrid of the hand
and the mouth in handwriting and so
we'll get to that in a moment but I just
want to sort of put that on the the
radar right away so he says from the
nature of the organ of activity to be a
passive being as well as the action
within it so there's already sort of a a
complex structure to the organ of
activity whether it's the hand the mouth
or something else in that it's involving
passivity and activity its passive visa
vie the inner for which it is indeed the
organ the tool right it's active in
respect to the external world which is a
world for others and we're
see how being for others plays into this
as well so he says from the fact that
the in itself NIST is itself present in
it now what is Miller translating by in
itself pneus or being for selfness as
I've got here we can say being in and
for itself well what we've got there is
on Zeke zine zelf stands ELPS is an
intensifier of it which means that it's
not just on Zeke sign that is being in
itself being like a piece of chalk being
something that merely has existence or
being something that is you know we
might say and I'm Zionist it just is
right it just has bear being rather the
inner and the tool hand right the mouth
has a being for itself that is a being
in itself this is an intensifier there's
a kind of you know reflexive relation
here that you know at least that's what
I'm reading and to hegel's use of the
zelfs there in relation to all the other
things that he that is saying so we're
not so interested in that I'm more
interested in this being for others that
comes up he says that the organ has a
being for others right he says we obtain
another view of it than the preceding
then what we've looked at before why is
he talking about being for others here
well you remember a few paragraphs
before we saw that there's this this
problem with externalizing oneself into
the world in that whatever you say
whatever you do can be taken up by
somebody else and interpret it in a
different way so the being for others
introduces an element of let's call it
uncertainty or
or risk later on however he's going to
talk about bills own when Miller is
translated as cultivation and education
this is a very important term for Hegel
and what is building well we talked
about this already way back in the
preface right the entire course of this
phenomenology of spirit is a history of
among other things building of the human
consciousness the cultivation the
development and it's something that goes
from generation to generation it doesn't
mean that it stays exactly the same but
it means that there's a kind of
continuity a kind of dependability a
kind of being able to build off of what
other people have left behind for you so
there's these two sides to being for
other there's the side of building which
is something that is he's going to say
affects the inner of the person right
and there's the side of well whatever i
do could kind of get lost in the shuffle
of so many other beings and this is a
contrast that Hagel's not drawing here
but I want to bring up because it's one
that runs throughout Hagel's work the
sort of you know breaking up the you
know being torn asunder Zeus durden
right and the long steady cultivation
that goes from generation to generation
these are both sides of the fact that we
exist as human beings in a world of
others so that all that by way of
preface let's go on he says if the
organs in general show themselves as
being in it to being capable of being
taken as expressions of the inner
because in them the action qua action is
present but the action qua completed
deed becomes merely external and in turn
out ER in this way fall apart and can be
alien to each other then the organ must
now take a more
give roll the organ must now in
accordance with its nature is that's a
very interesting thing to say in
accordance with its nature what in the
nature of the hand or the mouth means
that it has to be a middle term for the
externality the out Ernest of the world
a world of others and the inner of Who I
am in myself in my angles going to say
my innate peculiarities what about
something worth thinking about I'm not
going to try to answer that right now
but keep that in mind the sentence goes
on and he says here we go the organ was
now in accordance with his nature be
taken also as a middle term of both
immediate term between inner and outer
he says the very fact that the action is
present in it constitutes an externality
of it a simple externalities is he's
going to call it why is simple
externality well because it can take
many forms simple by the way here is not
the same thing as single as we're going
to see right so he says here we go the
the organ remains with and in the
individual now this middle term and
unity of inner and outer is in the first
place itself external to so it seems
like we can draw a line here right but
no it's part of the person says then
this externality is at the same time
taken up into the inner why well what
the hell is it doing there in the first
place it's somebody's hand it's
somebody's mouth and so it's not purely
external its external we might say in a
metaphorical way in so far as maybe
their soul is internal and the body of
the hand is external it's how they
interface with the rest of the universe
but its inner is part of the
individuality so he goes on
as as simple externality it stands over
against the dispersed externality the
scattered externality what is the
scattered externality well Hagel tells
us here in terms of the hand that in
terms of language or in terms of other
things that are expressive in this way
then what we have on the one hand is the
simple deed that's how Miller is
translating vehic the thing that is is
done or we might even say the thing that
is made right or the condition the
conditions is the douche stunned so we
can have the hand generating something
single or it can be generating a
totality it can be understood as
generating a whole bunch of deeds and
conditions and in both cases like he
says we have in the second case we have
fate split up into a multiplicity of
deeds and conditions and says thus the
simple lines of the hand the timber and
compass of the voice as the individual
characteristic of speech this too is
expressed in writing we're going to come
back to that in a moment all this is an
expression of the inner so that as a
simple externality as how it interfaces
the expression stands over again against
the manifold externality of action and
fate stands in relation to them as an
inner so the organ is functioning as
inner and outer and we might say you
know the inner here is actually an outer
in respect to the inner and this outer
here is an inner in with respect to the
fully outer so what do we have going on
here let's come back to this this issue
of writing now this is this question so
he says
writing is where the hand gives speech
more durable existence than the voice
does in that an interesting thing to say
now we don't have to get into a whole
you know long disquisition media or
anything like that but let's think you
know just for a moment about what's
going on here you're hearing my voice by
the time that you hear my voice I'm no
longer saying these things we already
talked about this way way back in the
you know first section of the
phenomenology when we were talking about
said certainty didn't we and we talked
about the you know fact that when you
talk the the voice is already dying out
as you're saying it even more so with
this recorded stuff when I write are
actually in my case much more often when
I'm typing what's going on is that
expressive of me is at my hand or is
that my voice or is it a weird amalgam
of both is it a third thing what about
when we record it and we put it out
there on the internet and it's being
placed into some sort of ether that what
we call the cloud because we have to
have a metaphor for its these massive
server farms which ultimately are
supposed to is we you know tell us boil
down to zeros and ones and circuits how
is that containing the individuality
that's speaking to another into that if
ended individuality that's you on the
other end what about when you write your
comment is that expressive of your
individuality or using an organ you're
you're using the organ of organs right
the hand but it's it's expressing what
you would like to say so that's a very
important thing to keep in mind we're
going to come back to this issue of
writing several times he says
if at first the specific nature and
innate peculiarity of the individual
that's the inner right together with
what these have become as a result of
cultivation and education are taken as
the inner as the essence of his action
and fate then this essence has its
appearance and externality to begin with
in the organ in his mouth in his hand
voice those that Hagel's saying voice
here and something different than mouth
otherwise weiss and what is it that a
boys can do well he talked about the
tone and the timbre of the voice earlier
that should be important for us that he
talks about handwriting right and the
other organs and their permanent
characteristics doesn't name what those
are and he says thereafter and not till
then does it give itself further outward
expression in its actual existence in
the world it's not as if we can sort of
automatically just interface with the
world without there being and mediating
as he's calling it here organ so why is
this important well because
physiognomies is going to be spending
its time looking at that Morgan and
Hagel wants us to look at it in a
different way